with Wesley so vuan acopian Matthew lson
and Spencer fold at the helm the St
Louis archbishops are the champions of
the US chess League after last week's
victory over the Dallas Destiny Wesley
so checkmated Conrad Holt on Board
number one and board number two a Cobian
defeated Jeffrey Jong boards three and
four were different stories for the
archbishops as Matt Larson and Spencer
fold lost their games the match was
close once again just like in the semis
it was a 2-2 tie after regular match
play and now we go to a format that
we're familiar with in this playoff
season The Gauntlet tie break in the
first tiebreaker Spencer fold had white
and disposed of caric ramachandran he
switched colors in the second game fold
met Francisco Guadalupe II and had an
impressive come from behind draw both
players were eliminated that brought up
Matt lson as white for St Louis and
Jeffrey Jean for Dallas Jean put away
lson but tough times awaited Dallas both
teams had just two players left and now
the big guns akobian was too much to
handle for young Jeffrey Jean
defeating him with the black pieces and
now for Dallas it was all up to Grandmas
Conrad Holt but just like in the regular
championship match Conrad Holt was again
checkmated on the board by VAR akobian a
Cobian was 3 and0 in regular season
match play for the archbishops ending a
tremendous season with the
championship well there was certainly
some pressure because we had such a
strong team throughout the whole season
and if we didn't win this year it would
it would look bad you know sort of on
all of us you know all the players and
so anyway I came specifically for this
match from LA and I'm happy that I
played well today won the main game and
then played well in the playoffs to help
the archbishops to win the first US sale
title I kind of knew it probably going
to come down to us trying to eliminate
their L too you know so when I won the
first game with Jeffrey uh quite
comfortably as black again so and I felt
comfortable and then uh Conrad just
played the line that I knew really well
and in fact it was interesting that I
played today a practice game with Wesley
so same line in a Blitz game just we
were playing some Blitz and just trying
to get sharper before the round and then
suddenly the same exact position
occurred on the board this end game and
which I I have some previous experience
as well and uh playing with Wesley they
helped me a lot to play confidently and
I think uh KRA didn't defend well and
slowly he just uh got into a pretty much
losing position in that end game akobian
himself is no stranger to championships
as he helped the Seattle Sluggers win
their 2012 uscl Championship as well St
Louis's board one player Wesley so is
the 2014 MVP of the league so recently
just changed his Fay affiliation to the
USA we're sure to see more of him in the
future I mean this is the first title
for the Archbishop so I'm pretty sure
this is not the last so hopefully next
year we'll be champions again why that
would be the 2015 uscl Championship we
will see you next year from here in St
Louis